Вони - одні з найдивовижніших організмів на Землі, але в основному невидимі.
Їхня мережа розширюється та поєднує усі наші глобальні екосистеми, що відіграє важливу роль для всього життєвого циклу.
Гриби.
Царство грибів відігравало вирішальну роль в еволюції життя не тільки у прадавні часи, а й нині.
Вони розкладають майже все, поглинають деякі з найбільш небезпечних забруднювачів і навіть можуть створювати повністю нові матеріали.
Вони дивні й чарівні, та володіють властивостями, про які ви й гадки не мали.
Тож чи можуть вони допомогти прибрати безлад на нашій планеті?
Але спершу - що ж таке гриби насправді? Давайте дослідимо їхнє приховане існування.
Гриби, які ви кладете у своє різотто, бачите на своїх гнилих овочах або знаходите в лісі - це лише верхівка айсберга.
Вони - окреме царство, яке докорінно відрізняється від тварин і рослин.
Їхнє таємне життя виникло понад мільярд років тому, і під час еволюції гриби стали першовідкривачами того життя, яке ми нині знаємо.
Видобуваючи поживні речовини з гірських порід мільйони років тому,
вони допомагали рослинам розвиватися і виробляти кисень, роблячи наше життя можливим сьогодні.
Лише за кілька сотень мільйонів років ці мікроскопічні форми життя перетворилися на справжніх гігантів.
На Аравійському півострові археологи знайшли скам’янілість, яку спочатку вважали деревом.
Але виявилося, що насправді це був 8-метровий гриб, який виріс 500 мільйонів років тому.
Справжня магія відбувається під поверхнею, де в основному росте міцелій - коренева мережа грибів.
Це найбільший відомий організм на планеті!
Міцелій величезної грибної системи в Орегоні поширюється на площу розміром 9 квадратних кілометрів
і, за оцінками експертів, має вік понад 8 з половиною тисяч років.
Гриби - одні з небагатьох організмів на планеті, які можуть значною мірою розщеплювати лігнін.
Це компонент клітин дерев, але також він є у плодах та будь-яких рослинах, які розкладаються після відмирання.
Якщо це накопичуватиметься у довкіллі, це шкідливо.
Тоді поживні речовини не будуть знову доступні для рослин або будь-якої іншої форми життя в ґрунті.
Тож дуже важливо, що є щось, що може це розкладати.
Еріка Коте - мікологиня з Університету Єни в Німеччині. Вона досліджує симбіоз між рослинами та грибами.
Гриби необхідні для підтримки здоров’я наших ґрунтів, і науковці тільки починають досліджувати їхні дивовижні здібності.
Якщо гриби можуть допомогти у розкладанні живого організму, що є більш складним, ніж будь-яка органічна сполука,
то цей самий набір організмів також може допомогти в розщепленні будь-яких органічних забруднювачів у довкіллі.
Удеме Діксон читає лекції з аналітичної хімії довкілля в Університеті Редінга у Великобританії.
Він вивчає, як гриби потенційно можуть допомогти очистити землю від нафтового забруднення.
У нас є багато досліджень, які доводять, що гриби розкладають токсичні речовини.
Близько 44-ох тисяч нафтових родовищ у всьому світі, незаконний видобуток і витоки на нафтопереробних заводах і з нафтопроводів
спричинили приблизно 5 мільйонів забруднених нафтою місць на планеті.
Паливо та сира нафта містять широкий спектр забруднюючих речовин.
Серед них поліциклічні вуглеводні є одними з найбільш небезпечних забруднювачів у наш час.
Вони вбивають флору і фауну, пошкоджують органи і можуть спричиняти рак у людей і тварин.
Ще в 1998 році вчені виявили, що гриби ростуть на сильно забруднених нафтою ґрунтах.
У даному випадку це гливи. Через 8 тижнів загальна кількість забруднювачів у ґрунті знизилася на 99%.
При цьому поліциклічні вуглеводні також розщеплюються на менш токсичні речовини.
Оскільки органічні забруднювачі, такі як мазут, походять з мертвої органічної речовини,
гриби розкладають їх за допомогою того ж ферменту, яким розкладають деревину та листя.
Забруднюючі речовини подрібнюються на менші сполуки, які є менш небезпечними або й зовсім нешкідливими,
тому вони можуть знову стати частиною циклу поживних речовин.
Деякі з них розкладаються до CO2 або воду.
Концепція повернення до організмів, які природно діють за правилом розкладання та використання цих організмів
для знищення забруднюючих речовин у довкіллі є дуже перспективним шляхом.
Грибами також можна обробляти ґрунти, забруднені миш'яком, свинцем і ртуттю внаслідок гірничих робіт
або навіть забруднення радіоактивними елементами.
У 1986 році вибух ядерного реактора в Чорнобилі призвів до руйнівного радіоактивного забруднення,
зробивши цей регіон непридатним для життя й нині.
В експерименті біля ядерного реактора Еріка Коте використовувала гриби разом з місцевими рослинами.
Нам вдалося показати, що стронцій, який є радіоактивним елементом, що половина біодоступного стронцію
може поглинатися соняшником протягом 12-тижневого періоду росту, поки ми не зберемо врожай.
Згодом рослини можна зрізати, спалити, а збагачений стронцієм попіл можна буде зберігати безпечніше.
Ґрунт стане значно чистішим.
Що гриби роблять тут - це змінюють рухливість елементів, закріплюючи їх у ґрунті, поглинаючи їх або допомагаючи рослинам вбирати їх.
Зразки, взяті поблизу російського промислового майданчика, показали,
що гриби накопичують до 40 разів більше нікелю та міді, ніж ґрунт, в якому вони росли.
Тож, можливо, людство вже має рішення для сильно забрудненого ґрунту.
Але якими би багатообіцяючими не були деякі експерименти, багато з них також провалилися.
Це означає, що у мене є 10 різних експериментальних установок, і в семи все відбулося добре, а в трьох - ні, чи навпаки.
Тож я не можу покласти це як основу для запровадження в дію реальних схем санації.
Обробка ґрунтів грибами можлива на відносно невеликих ділянках.
Це дешевше та екологічніше, ніж звичайні методи видалення та спалювання.
Однак це непростий метод, особливо для цілих лісів чи регіонів видобутку корисних копалин.
Екосистеми - унікальні. І гриби, переміщені з іншої території, не обов’язково ростуть у них.
Вирощування місцевих видів грибів, які можуть виконувати цю роботу, було б принциповим рішенням цієї проблеми,
але це вимагає багато часу і терпіння.